there's some kid who's the next re gold
that's sitting on kentucky's campus or
alabama's campus
that's going to end up being like worth
50 100 million dollars and they're going
to get their start by selling name image
like this
like local deals to for the local
players i feel like i can rule the world
i know i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back
all right this was a jammed pack episode
we talked about a lot
so we talked about buying lottery
tickets online and how that might become
a big business
we talked about what else we talked
about we talked about um athlon
we talked about a company called flights
about um creating quickbooks for ncaa
athletes
what else we talk about the business of
mug shots mug shots yes
mug shots the business how these
websites make money why they are posting
mug shots online
and uh and how we feel about that is
that scummy or is that uh is that legit
we also talk about a couple ideas for
chrome extensions there's chrome
extensions that keep you focused
we talked about porn addiction fighting
and if that's a big market or not
so get to the episode uh can you guys do
us a favor
leave a review and then click like and
subscribe or click subscribe if you're
on itunes and then
follow up here on spotify and leave a
review and let us know what you think
about this episode
talk soon if if you are not watching on
youtube
check out the youtube channel you can
see our faces most people have our
voices mixed up they think
what they think me i am sad but sam is
me the only way to know is to go to
youtube that's the number one comment we
get
we actually reply in all the comments
like we can't reply to
podcast reviews but i actually go
personally reply to the youtube comments
on every episode
so go subscribe there because uh
honestly the youtube channel is
better than the podcast feed so if
you're only on the podcast feed
you're missing out go to youtube the
channel is called
sam what is it called just go to youtube
and type in my first mill and you'll see
it right now it's called the hustle but
they'll see it and then hit the
subscribe button all right i have a ton
of stuff to cover
thanks for wearing a shirt by the way
dude you get all
hot and bothered when i just don't have
sleeves man this this is a shirt
well i guess so we don't all
we don't all dress like you know
bouncers at a miami strip club so
[Laughter]
i do look like that i look like yeah
like a little special ed today uh
do you wanna um what do you got going on
i have a lot of interesting stuff
all right let's start let's do it um all
right
did you see everything that i put on
here uh
well it changed you had a whole bunch of
stuff about
greeting cards and now it's something
else buying lottery tickets all right go
for it
okay i got a lot of stuff i got lottery
tickets i got mug shots i got
um uh
oh the athletic stuff i actually let's
do
let's do lottery tickets first and then
i want to do athletic stuff because you
actually talked about that so i just
talked to this guy
i don't think i'm gonna do anything with
it i don't know yet but i just talked to
this guy and i thought it was really
amazing
now this company that i'm going to tell
you about it has to deal with the
powerball and lotteries
which i actually think that my uh stance
on it is i'm
personally not in favor of it i i i'm
not i'm not on board
but i thought it was fascinating so
there's these companies that are there's
two of them in the space
so basically the way it works is there's
two major lotteries there's the
powerball and mega millions and then
each state has a state-run lottery
okay and the way it works is you go to
the 7-eleven you go wherever and you buy
a ticket
so there's this company that i just
started talking to they're called spins
um and what they do is sorry slips
spins slips so you know have you heard
of this or you see did i write it down
i talked to them a bunch of months ago
and i talked about them on the pottery
but yeah but i did talk about it but we
could do it again that's okay
i don't remember you telling me about
them that's okay most people probably
don't
um but how did you hear about slips
i thought they just launched like a
month like this month it's been on test
flight for a long time
so i used it on test flight it's that's
what you do
it's clever dude i feel the wind was
blowing out of my sails just now
i'm sorry okay i'll give you a minute to
recover no i want you
i want you to explain now because you're
good at it i'll try to remember so
basically
um a lot of people play the lottery you
typically go to a 7-eleven or a gas
station or something you buy it
what these guys did was they let you
play the lottery from your phone legally
how do they do that well basically
wherever you are
you'll say i'd like to buy a lottery
ticket and then they will physically go
send somebody to a gas station
they'll buy the lottery ticket uh so
sort of like there's a task rabbit
essentially that'll go buy the lottery
ticket in person for you because you
can't actually buy them online
they'll buy it they'll take a photo of
it they'll sort of custody it online
and and give it to you and um and so
that's how they kind of bypass the rules
around
buying lottery like running an online
lottery you can't run an online lottery
but you can
pay somebody to go buy the ticket and
then they can give you the ticket
um and that's like their two-step
process did i think that's brilliant you
got it brilliant
or you got it right and i think that's
brilliant i think it's brilliant because
i never would have thought about that
and it's the easiest possible solution
and by the way
i think they simplified it even further
where they just paid the guy at the gas
station
to be the taskrabbit so now they don't
even dispatch somebody they're just like
hey
when this thing rings that's that's
somebody paying you
to buy a lottery ticket uh and you pay
like a little premium on top of what the
lottery ticket is and that's the kind of
like service
surcharge which might be like 25 cents
or a dollar or something it's not like
percentage-wise is pretty significant
but it's not a huge amount of money so
people don't care it's like ah it's more
convenient because they can i can get a
push notification it says
the lottery is 200 million dollars today
would you like a ticket and you just say
kind of like yes and that's that's low
friction uh i was saying they have
subscription they have a bunch of stuff
but when i was talking to this guy
i was thinking there's a few i was
thinking of the pros and cons
so pros of this business it's gonna get
big fast
[Laughter]
yeah i can see it getting big fast
that's the only pro
that's a big pro in the world of
business that's that's the main pro
that's the main pro there are so many
things about why
it won't work are you like why it won't
work are you saying basically like
ethically i have a problem with this
or well no that's just one of the many
things so like i wouldn't say ethically
i have a problem but i would have to ask
myself how i feel about that
like i would have to think about it so
in one regard it's like i don't buy the
lottery
and i don't want like if you don't have
a lot of money i don't think you should
buy the lottery that said
who am i to tell you what to buy and
also if you want to spend i go to the
casino and i like to spend 50
and that's fun so like who am i to say
what's like
who am i to judge but the second thing i
would imagine
a app like this would have very similar
economics uh
not similar economics but similar growth
tactics as like a mobile game which
means you have to be super aggressive
about uh
customer acquisition and if facebook
google
or that pretty much that's it if they
ban you you're [__]
yes that's that's a legit problem for
this
and that might be
the the big the two biggest what's that
also i think had some social feature
that was like
if you and your friend you and your
friends can kind of like share it you
could split tickets
or something like that like did they
they brought all the offline things
where like you know an office pulls
together
and buys 100 tickets and then they agree
to split the money i think they
brought that into it so it's a nice app
i liked the idea
i liked the idea a lot um but i just you
know
whatever there's a whole bunch of
reasons why i decided not to invest but
i just thought it was uh
i think it's a clever idea and i've been
looking at this for years so to your
question of how do i find this
is because for years i've been thinking
about how how would you bring the
lottery online and i've
talked to many people who claimed they
could do it legally and it wasn't
actually legal or
it was only legal in one state to do it
that way and they were hoping all the
other states caught on
and so i've just been keeping an eye out
for rule changes and that's kind of a
theme
like we talked about the name and the
nil thing for the for college athletes
name image and likeness
rule change equals opportunity i have
another rule change i'm going to do
today
um that's another opportunity but this
is this is an example of one of those
types of businesses
you want to talk about that and i and i
nil stuff
yeah what do you got for it and the
reason so you brought this up
and i had known about it but i just saw
this other article did you see this
article that went viral about
this alabama kid hasn't even like
thrown a plate said he had a million
bucks in revenue booked for the year or
something crazy like that
well the funny thing is the coach nick
saban came out and he's the one who kind
of said it so he's like oh yeah you know
which creates a
weird situation like our freshman
quarterback
uh he's made seven figures you know he's
making all this money his teammates
aren't making that money it creates an
awkward dynamic
um but so some people there's really
three reactions to this one is like okay
maybe there's some truth to that
the second is oh is this like for years
there's been all kinds of people who
make millions of dollars like
nick saban does nick saban makes tens of
millions of dollars at the coach
and all the players played for free and
it's like dude you're trying to keep the
players down
now that they're making a buck you got a
problem with it and then there's the
third one which is the super mega evil
version of this which was
he added this line at the end where he
goes
he's like he's making all this money and
that's because of our brand
that's because he's a quarterback at
alabama which is true it became a
recruiting pitch
at the same time so he was fake being
outraged
but really was what they call dog
whistling dog
whistling to all the other you know high
school athletes right now
and you come to alabama that check is
pretty big uh this guy hasn't even
played yet and he's getting this type of
money imagine
what you'll get when you come if you
come here and so all the other college
coaches the players were mad at him the
coaches were mad at him and the media
was mad at him i loved it it was a
master
a master stroke what i actually did was
we
contacted i i went and contacted some
folks in the compliance industry
at schools and they made a comment that
said they're explicitly banned
from finding or facilitating any type of
deals
for athletes the school is yes yeah so
like nick saban can't
like you know they can't be the middle
man at all but
um what they're able to do is act
and so the reason i'm bringing this up
is you had this idea where it
i mean i guess it's a fairly obvious
thing but you said it well uh of like
you have to have this software
or some type of compliance software in
order to manage these relationships and
manage those deals
these deals and i have an example as to
why that's kind of important but
so the school can't it can't be the
middleman but they have to be
in the loop about what you're doing the
school will definitely pay which is why
i was saying you should build
a tool like this with transparency
visibility
reporting payments infrastructure
because the schools will have to pay and
once they pay they're locked in
because you're going to be the system of
record of how the athletes are making
money and i want to give an example let
me give you an example of a very
very very specific example about why
this is going to get really complicated
so do you know american top team i bet
you do it's that
it's a corset yeah so it's a a mixed
martial art gym in florida
they offered 500 a month to miami's
entire 90 scholarship football players
to advertise their gyms on social media
so that's 540
000 but every player has to do it now
there's
like these crazy there's these crazy
rules and so
here's an example um an example of the
gym deal for many players we mentioned
the contract states that they must
advertise for the gym over social media
but if they lose track and not and all
90 athletes do not post
technically that's a pay for play and
not an n a n i
l deal and it's a major nc nc double a
minor
so it doesn't matter if you understand
that what matters is that
it's incredibly complicated and that
this is going to get like really
complicated i wonder if somebody can
also just
build the other side just build the uh
build the irs
so it's like build the little police the
independent police
task force that's going to be monitoring
all this stuff and finding
potential violations and then selling
this service back to the schools which
is like hey we found some athletes that
are out of code here
that this is actually against the thing
we will sell you
this type of visibility so that you guys
don't fall out of compliance that's
another way to do it is
you uh you diagnose the problem and then
you sell them the prescription
that line is going to lead me into my
next point that's a totally different
topic but
when we talked about that uh when we
talked about this ncaa thing did a lot
of companies reach out to you
yeah there was a bun no they didn't
reach out they go bro we're already
doing this we've been doing this
that's what i mean that's what i mean
yeah good good good for you great i i
agree it's a good opportunity
i don't know why you gotta get all
defensive about it any any
anything interesting uh you know i
didn't really look into them because
i didn't have time but i think like open
doors was one of the ones that a bunch
of people mentioned
i don't know if that's like the number
one uh i i kind of think that it's not
really going to be some player that's
been around for a while i think it's
going to be somebody
i i view it as in these markets it's
whoever
builds this first simple useful thing
will get a ton of adoption and then it's
then it's a race between the people who
tried to build the big valuable thing
and the group that got a bunch of
adoption to go from small and simple
to more thorough and whoever where do
those lines cross
which which group gets there first and i
like to bet on the horse
where the founders identify identified
hey this is a simple thing that we can
get in the hands of every athlete right
now or every school right now
and we can even give it away for free as
long as we get them hooked into our
our system we have a relationship with
them i think those are going to be the
interesting one so i'm kind of looking
for who's new um
but i'm open-minded about it i haven't i
haven't seen anybody make it make a very
compelling case that they've got
something good going
but i do have an idea around this if
you're ready for it so
are you familiar with how um sports
agents make their money like if i'm a
agent for an nba basketball player do
you know roughly like how that money
shakes out no so so basically
um if i'm an agent for an nba player i'm
gonna take
let's call it two to three percent on
average um and i'm not an expert of this
that may be more nuanced to it but this
is what i have a couple friends who do
this and this is what they told me
so um they make about two to three
percent of the contract value so let's
say
in the nba like a max guy might make 40
million a year so let's say you have two
guys you got a max
player and you have his buddy on the
team who's kind of a bit of a mid-level
player
and you have 50 million 50 million a
year from the team
you're gonna make two percent so you're
gonna make a million dollars a year as
an agent so you can stack some pretty
good money
now it is a absolutely cutthroat and
ruthless business where they're all
trying to backstab each other and steal
each other's clients
um and it is like a slightly dirty
industry where there's a lot of sort of
like bribery
wine you know some on the good end
whining and dining and on the bad end
sort of like
bribery and [__] talking that goes on in
order for agents to get clients
but i have a few uh ben was telling me
about a few friends of his that have
an agency as three people and their
athletes under contract
will bring in about three million total
a year and so basically the main guy the
main agent is probably banking 2.6
million 2.5 million himself
and then the other 500k goes into like
operations and paying the other two
people they're kind of like salary so
how much is the total the contract value
will be
i think he takes three percent so the
contract value was something like 75
million
uh just for rough numbers for the year
there's like four players right
and so and it's like yeah it's really
hard to get your foot in the door but
when you have this guy like
typically the players will stick with
you unless they have a problem with you
you mess up
and so you get their like 10 to 15 year
career sometimes
and then as long as that player has a
name you can use them and their
introductions to get like a couple other
guys on the team that they're buddies
with that they trust when they're
looking for agents
and then they keep going down market so
they keep trying to get guys like
right before the draft or you know in
college they're you know
showing up on campus and just talking to
the guy trying to not create an ncaa
violation but
build those relationships so what i was
thinking was so that's the gener
general business i don't think it's a
great business to be in but
uh you know whatever it's kind of
there's a few people that win big and
then most people get nothing
the opportunity i saw was well with this
name
image likeness i think this is going to
breed a whole new set
of college hustlers that become sports
agents
why is that because i'm a player at a
school
if i'm just some kid in the same dorm
like i remember when i was on duke
campus i bumped into
you know gerald henderson on the first
day of orientation
and um and he actually kind of a funny
story he was like
we kind of were hitting it off which is
great because normally
these guys you know everyone's mobbing
them they don't care about you they're
looking for like the hottest girl around
they don't really care about this brown
indian dude what why am i talking to him
but we hit it off we're joking around
and he goes oh man like what are you
doing tonight
i was like oh i think we're going to
west campus i didn't even know what that
was at the time was my first day on
campus but i just said something i
thought sounded cool he's like
he's like oh i'm sick like hit me up
when you go like here take my number
and um i had finished high school in
china and so i actually didn't even have
a cell phone the first day of college i
was like
getting my plans set up and so i was
like oh you know i don't have a phone
but he he just looked at me like oh bro
you don't have a phone
and he just like walked away that was
the last i talked to him but
the opportunity is dude you could have
been friends with an nba player
i know i know i blew it i blew it many
many times after that too with other
players
um but basically let's say i'm friends
with that guy
i could just go hustle i could go to the
local car dealership
and i could be like hey how much would
you pay gerald to be on this billboard
right he's a big name in this college
town so you'll give him 1500 bucks and i
could go to gerald and say hey dude i
got you a 1500
deal all you got to do is like say yes
and take this photo
and then he would be like oh sick man
and if i did that three more times
i'm pretty sure i could be this guy's
like business manager within like two
months of being in college
and if you just plant those seeds at
that stage because you're on campus
you're one of them
you could work the scene locally i'm
pretty sure that that's one way to like
hit your wagon to someone who's a future
nba player and actually become an agent
so i think
you're gonna find some super agents that
come out of this like
this one rule change there's some kid
who's the next ari gold
that's sitting on kentucky's campus or
alabama's campus
that's going to end up being like worth
50 100 million dollars and they're gonna
get their start by selling name image
like this
like local deals to for the local
players yeah i mean that's what a lot of
people have done with music
you know scooter braun started that way
um
what was his origin story so i i know
who we have okay so
if you don't know who scooter braun is
he um owned this company called
ithaca holdings which i think just sold
to
uh a korean music label for three or
four billion dollars scooter bronze most
famous for
yeah ethical holding just sold is he
like a billionaire
uh yeah probably wow
to tell you ability you didn't even know
about how do you feel bro
there i just want to do it there you go
i feel great i love it how much did it
sell for
all right so he sold it to hybe which is
the korean
entertainment conglomerate that owns i
think they they have the rights to bts
which is like the biggest yeah
yeah in the world or something um let's
see what's the sale price
i'll look it up you keep talking um
anyway so he sold this company
he was most famous for being justin
bieber's manager but he also managed
uh ariana grande and a few other people
he's only 35 36 37 very young
you'll see him in some of the music
videos he was also famous because he
bought
big machine records based out of
nashville which owned taylor swift's
rights
and he bought that for only like 80
million dollars even though it made 40
million
a year something crazy like that and he
got a start out of emory university i
believe and when he was a sophomore
somehow he started throwing parties and
in doing so
uh met jermaine dupri's mom who owned a
record label
in atlanta where emery is mrs dupree
it's
is that you well mrs dupree is like the
head honcho of
a of a meaningful like production and
music
and he starts working for him and he and
and
the dupries and he's like doing this
music thing and he's like bringing
people all the he's bringing all the
kids to
college parties as a club promoter and
making a cut to like a german degree
party
then eventually when he's 22 he has a
little bit of money save but not a lot
like less than a hundred grand
he finds this guy on youtube who is a
little kid he's like
seven eight nine ten years old and he's
playing the guitar and he's playing a
guitar and he's singing
and scooter goes this kid's gonna be a
home run
he's gonna be a winner so he flies his
kid and his mom down to
uh atlanta and he goes i want to manage
you and the kid's like i don't what do
you mean management i don't have a
career he goes you're gonna be a
superstar one day
and that was justin bieber and he uh so
he discovered the biebs and he made tens
of millions of dollars off that and then
recently made a billion plus from
selling his company what did he sell it
for
one one billion so it was 1.05 billion
so
so just two quick numbers so they sold
for 1.05 billion and he had acquired
that big machine like label thing with
taylor swift's rights for 300 million
back
oh okay so my numbers are off um rich
whatever
um and so and let's just go through some
more numbers braun now holds a one
percent stake in hybe
which is worth 123 million itself the
bts members each have 18 million
in so there's seven of them um
and then bieber and ariana grande have
14.3 million dollars worth
of worth of a stake in hybe uh high went
public at 1.5 billion and it's doubled
in the last few months i would have
bought this if i knew that the company
behind bts had gone public
uh but i was not i was not awake at the
wheel here
so kind of interesting i don't even know
how we got on it but but he got started
in
in college promoting bieber and he also
you know who his second act was uh
asher roth the guy who
and he and at the time he was like this
asher roth guy is going to be
with the biggest he's going to be the
biggest yeah yeah but ashley roth came
to him after doing i love college and
he's
like you know i kind of like don't
really want to be famous like i don't
want to
like be in the limelight i just want to
be quiet and so he bailed on him
respect so okay we should do we should
do more on scooter and i've been also
there's a billionaire behind bts this
guy like he's amazing
what his name is i'm gonna do a deep
dive on this guy uh banksy hook
uh so we'll we'll we'll go on to this
guy let me tell you another story
are you gonna reference one thing by the
way just one regret i have is that
i did not hustle in college i
i had like very small small like tiny
schemes like i was a schemer i've always
been a skeemer
but i was such a goldfish guppy schemer
back then i was trying to like
find a way to win the monopoly game at
mcdonald's and i was trying to like
you know get into the easiest classes i
was thinking small
and with my buddies and we started like
a sushi restaurant thing but like
had i now that i think about it college
this four-year playground
with a whole bunch of potential
co-founders all around you with a whole
bunch of potential customers all around
you
with nothing but free time and nothing
but energy and no
mortgage no nothing it's all paid for
it's a giant summer camp
damn that's that was the time to take
some shots take some experiments so if
you're listening
to this or you know something so send
them this clip
it's also the time to get drunk hook up
with girls hook up with dudes
try on different hats and explore
yourself you don't have to have the
pressure to like make money
i'm not saying become successful i'm
saying take some shots hustle a little
bit
and that doesn't mean don't party that
means um
the way i prioritize things was was just
dumb which was like i don't know
sleep number one class number two
friends number three you know it's like
i thought i thought college was about
the classes and college is
obviously not almost almost not about
the classes in any any shape or form but
it
but the illusion is that it's about
classes in a little bit i want to talk
about the fat fire thing
that i mentioned the other day and you
kind of said something to me but right
now
or do you wanna talk about that now you
wanna talk about some mug shot [__]
i got one other little quick quick
college hustle
uh idea there's another rule change to
be aware of
this rule change came from angellist
angelus made it where
it's now very easy for anybody who does
any professional investors anybody like
me or you who invests
millions of dollars a year into startups
we can now make
it's very trivially easy to create a
scout program to have anybody become a
scout for our program which all that
means is
you bring a great deal to me if i invest
you get a piece of the upside
so you get to free free roll into
investments and you get to network with
real investors and you get to be
basically hunting startups for fun
i was doing this but back back when i
was i think i've talked about before the
first angel investment i ever did i did
as a scout
i found a deal i diligenced it i thought
it was a great deal i
pitched that deal to somebody who had
money and they were like great i'll give
you a piece of the upside
and um and there was no like you know i
was like we have to figure out our own
paperwork for that well you know it
wasn't like a
easy one-click button like angeles has
now made it well they've had this i've
used this for my thing
on the back end but splitting deal by
deal carry wasn't easy for funds or
rolling funds before i think for sbvs it
might have been
but now it's easy for everybody so i so
if you're interested in investing
the game has changed here's what i would
do my quick 30 seconds of what i would
do if i was somebody who didn't have the
money to invest in startups but i love
the idea of startup investing
i would contact my four favorite
investors maybe it's you know
me and three other people great
me me and me so your four favorite
investors the top four investors shawn
and sean i got four email addresses so
here's what you do you send an email and
you say
you don't say hey can i work for you you
say hey every week uh hey i love
startups i am a junkie i'm always
looking for
for interesting startups that are on the
come up uh you know i'm
a developer so i know about that or i'm
into music so i'm watching the music
scene or whatever right you figure out
what your what your angle is
and then you just say i'm gonna send you
three interesting startups a week
you don't you don't have to reply but if
anything catches your eye or you think
it's either really stupid or really
awesome
i love a one line reply and you just
start sending that for three weeks
straight and if i don't reply after
three weeks you ditch me and you
figure out somebody else but if you do
this you'll walk
you'll do two things it'll be fun
because it's fun to just check out
startups and
play that game a fantasy investor but b
you'll actually walk away within a year
you'll have a portfolio of startups that
you have equity in that you sourced that
due diligence and that you pitched
and that that's like a great way to
break into this industry so i think
angel's just made it way easier to break
in i just wanted to put that out as a
psa for people
yeah and just go ahead drop your email
yeah sean seanpuri.com um all right so
a minute ago you said something that was
actually really brilliant
and it was about the ncaa stuff and what
you would do is you would find the
violations and go to ncaa
and or go to uh like you know university
alabama and be like hey this your
quarterback is actually breaking the
rules here the
the fines are x y and z uh a buy our
software for
why uh way easier sell than buy our
software
it's hey you have a problem here it is
if you if you don't wanna have this
problem in the future we obviously we do
it look i did it for you already
so there's this remember earlier a month
ago i mentioned the business of mugshots
correct
that's right you told me about
mugshots.com i think it was yeah
and so i went and did a bunch of
research on these businesses
there's a whole ecosystem of this so i'm
going to name
a bunch of them so um it's let's see
where are they okay
so um mugshots.com gets at least 600 000
visitors a month
bustedmugshots.com 666 000 visitors a
month five
find mugshots.com seventy two thousand
visitors listed mug chats that's just
ugly people
ugly mudshots is that what that is i
don't know the same thing
i think it's the same it busted like in
jail not like your face is busted
arrest.org 4.35 million
truthfinder.com 9.1 million and then
be ver been verified 23 million visits
and so these are all centered around
mugshots and criminal records
now you want to hear how these guys make
money so what they do
is and and here's a a story so
there's this guy matt creed in kansas
city and he started this company called
blabbermouth in 2013 and what he would
do is
he would post names and addresses and
mugshots of local people who had already
been arrested
then he would mail them all letters and
say we have already been blabbing to the
world about your release from jail and
we want to make you aware of our
services as we kind of have a big mouth
and for 200 we will remove all the
information from our website
and they would send that to people and
that is exactly
what mugshots.com does that's what
arrest.com does that's what
busted org.com it's free search
pay to be removed from the database
scrubbed from the from from their search
not only that there's a whole bunch of
removal services so there's remove
slander.com
removearrest.org or racemugshot.com
who charge one thousand to five thousand
dollars to actually just
do this to all the to all the companies
i
imagine what they do is they just charge
you five grand and then they go and pay
all the websites
each like 50 bucks like they just have
some affiliate deal and they just take a
little bit of profit
there's probably some rule there's
probably some dmca type rule where if i
request to be taken out and you have to
take me down that's probably what it is
that's my guess i
don't know if that's right but i feel
like they may not have to pay anything
it's just
going and filing the claim so in in vast
in the vast majority of states posting
photos online
of uh these mug shots is totally legal
okay so you you can't you you really
can't get a
it's not a big deal to post them it's
public record where the gray area is is
that the websites uh that populate them
they
put the mug shots on there and then they
turn around like and charge
individuals money to remove them um
then now a lot of these guys who run
these websites like microsoft.com they
the authorities are trying to look for
anything little that they do wrong
or anything that it didn't matter how
small but they wanted to do something
wrong like for example like embezzle a
little bit of money which
i i think that there's like a try
figuring out if someone is embezzled
like
you could probably catch that mistake
it's like if they don't file their taxes
correctly you know what i mean
and so the founders have actually been
locked up for like three four five
months at a time
and a lot of these websites if you go
and try and find we i went and
researched them you try to find out
who owns them it's different domains
in panama belize things like that it's
like this huge web
but it's incredibly fascinating there's
this entire ecosystem
around mug shots and then mugshots
removal and it's very fascinating very
interesting i think it's horrible but
it's
interesting nonetheless tell me you're
shady without telling me you're shady
and then you
post your your cayman islands uh
incorporation documents or your belize
you know headquarters address dan dan
come on come on microphone real quick
you're a good human being
i would say dan is a extremely straight
edged human being from what i could tell
and dan tell me this when i hear
sam explain these businesses by
literally my
first reaction is awesome that was wow
so smart how they thought of that
and i think you probably or like many
people have a different reaction which
is sort of like
geez these guys like whoever does this
is kind of a scumbag
tell me dan what is your reaction to
this yeah i just chatted to you i i said
the owners of all these companies are
human garbage
and so is that your reaction with sam
describes these as like ugh
gross or is it like like my reaction was
awesome
i mean there's lots of ways to make
money in this world that just sounds
like a horrible one
that's a good point okay fair enough so
i i i i'm not like people
i do not like this i would never do this
i think these guys are pieces of [__]
and also i think it's amazing like like
i think that like
do so doing what this guy matt did of
like sending the letter that's like
table stakes any schemer
who has ever wanted to do that like
already schemer out there who's been
like 19 like
that's such this is the most this is
some basic [__] [__] i think this is
like the most basic like
scam i would imagine but uh no i would
never in a million years do it and i
wouldn't want to be friends with anyone
who does it
and yeah i still think it's fascinating
and interesting
right so there's like uh would i do it
no uh
do i think other people should be
allowed to do it maybe yes or no
if somebody does it do i consider them a
piece of [__] or do i consider them
like you know it's fair game it's just
not one it's not for me right like
uh i think those are the kind of to me
that's like the moral question
question box i i get into with stuff
like this but
uh i don't know i think these are very
clever very smart i think they
to me i'm always like wow
okay yeah i wouldn't do it but huh
that's interesting
what like if you just piece it together
there's a bunch of layers one layer is
oh man you can create businesses just
taking public data that's not really
formalized for
for kind of like consumers to like use
and you could like aggregate it create a
search engine on top of it you can
create a product there
yeah people do that with zillow people
do that with many things so
it's just one generic business model
type so then you say oh cool if i ever
find
other public things that are public
record but i don't know that there's a
main consumer
consumer website for it i could build
that then there's like
huh there's some psychology why are so
many people why are millions of people
going to these websites
what is there like is it just like a
gossip thing
is it that they are trying to solve some
problem like they had some theft and
they they wrote down some guy's license
plate they're trying to figure out who
it is
oh maybe there's a maybe there's a
consumer problem to be solved here
and then there's like the business model
innovation or the business model tactic
which is
the same thing i was saying earlier
about ncaa violations which is
you don't sell the the search you sell
the removal
right you sell the solution once they
search and uh okay that's interesting
too so i i
like i look at it as a bunch of
different layers and then when i put the
whole thing together i'm like yeah
that's kind of crappy
but like as individual layers it's
pretty fascinating to me
it's fascinating you want to talk about
porn yeah let's do it you saw this thing
i wrote down
yeah all right so i saw this company
that's in yc right now
and i don't know how did you wait first
of all how do you see
all this interesting stuff that's like
saying
you know how how do you pull off that
shirt man i don't know you just do it
you don't even think about it
uh this case this was on hacker news it
was a it was posted as a show
hn so i check out hacker news when i go
to hacker news
i typically will go to the show tab
because i find that to be more
interesting than the news
and uh and then i think in this case ben
sent this to me
yesterday when we were talking about
something that we were just bullshitting
about something else related
and then he's like oh yeah there's
another company like this that's kind of
interesting he was laughing at it
and i was like no i actually think
that's like a legit idea he's like what
do you mean
i was like well i think these taboo
ideas so in this case
this is a company that helps people who
are addicted to porn
fight their addiction so it's a great
treatment so it's like alcoholics
anonymous
for people who are are uh compulsive
with porn
and i'll get you addicted to this app so
he sent it to me as a joke like
um dude look at this and i was sort of
like
i bet that's actually a big problem i
bet there's a lot of people who have
this problem
and i bet there's kind of nothing
there's no real legit company that's
occupying that space why not why why
wouldn't there be something that
occupies a space that helps a lot of
people
and so i started looking into it so they
have about a hundred thousand
members of their community they say i
don't know if that means just registered
people explain the product
i'm explaining product so the it's an
overall company that's supposed to help
you overcome a digital addiction
so it wasn't just for porn but they
started out with a few different
products
so they had the first one they had was
called detox
and all it was is basically it was an
app that would just like
get you off your phone for a period of
time it would kind of like lock you off
your phone and just tell you
don't use your phone for the next four
hours you're detoxing
okay cool and by the way i've i've
wanted to do this myself
i kind of made a rule for myself one
hour a day i'm just gonna
lose my phone i i don't need my phone
every hour of the day
um the next one they created was socialx
that's your personal role that's my
personal yeah
i didn't know about this app but i just
i just put my phone in one different
room and i just leave it for an hour
um then there's social dude
[Music]
yeah that's a lot for me i was constant
on my phone dude
me too and so what i do is i just uh i
don't i
yeah i only use it from nine a.m to
six work hours and then i just leave it
oh my god what do you do for fun
um well so i'm trying so
i mean i i i hear your killer in your
night times what do you do
i do have it on me sometimes i just use
airplane mode all the time so you just
can't contact me like i just won't see
any
messages what do you just use it as a
clock or uh
like if i were working out i'll use
headphones or music
right okay but that's it wow so after 6
p.m
if i text you you're just not gonna get
it or like you get an
instagram comment or something you just
don't look at it
no i don't look at instagram comment no
no of course not no
uh if you called me if you called me i
would probably see your number and pick
up but if it's anyone else i'm not
like if you're outside the circle yeah
i'm not gonna talk to you well good for
you man that's
that's really good i think that's i
think you're saying it like it's a
normal thing and
and when you say it all out it sounds
perfectly reasonable i think like less
than one percent of people well
let me tell you this this quick story i
heard about an
earl nightingale you know what earl
nightingale is no what's that so he's
this uh
he was around in the 60s probably the
40s and 50s actually and he was a radio
host and he would tell interesting
stories but he's also kind of
business-minded so a lot of like he was
like the tony robbins of the day
and he told the story about how he um
went to a farmer's house one time
and this was right when phones just got
created and
he was at this farmer's house i forget
what he was talking to him about but the
farmer's phone was rigging and it was
going off and going off and earl was
just kind of looking at the farmer
and the farmer just kept looking at him
having a normal conversation and then
the phone went away and then it started
ringing again and kept going and
earl finally goes hey you know mister
like your phone's been going off
aren't you gonna answer that and he goes
why would i answer that he goes well
someone's calling you
but he goes sir i installed this phone
in in here for my convenience not their
convenience
and i don't feel like answering it right
and that's now how i ch
my opinion now toward my phone is is
like no this is here for me not for
anyone else
i uh i similarly i picked up a phrase
like that that i'll share that i've been
i've been like kind of playing with i
don't know if i'm like fully adopting
this because i feel like a dick
when i use it but my brother-in-law
was talking i was talking to him the
other day and he's uh he's
he's a successful guy in business and he
was like he was talking about um
i was asking about like a tax accountant
and i was like yeah my tax accountant's
saying this and i'm saying this
he goes i was like how do you do it he
was telling me how he runs his
relationship with his tax account i was
like oh wow that's kind of strange
uh like why do you do it that way or
like don't they ask or don't they don't
they like
want you to do xyz and he's like
are they paying me or am i paying them
and i was like
you're paying them he goes okay so then
we're gonna like if i'm paying you
then we're gonna do this a certain way
and if you're paying me we're to do it a
certain way
he goes so many times you see people who
pay someone for a service
and then cater to the other person as if
they're being paid by them and i
started to see this at first you said i
just kind of laughed it off
i do
[Laughter]
i'm not fixing this i'm paying this
woman to do it right i think i even said
this to dan the other day i was like uh
dan was talking something about like uh
the schedule this of this
of like our recordings or whatever he's
like oh it's getting real late you know
because you guys are always like kind of
last minute and all their deadlines
and i i just had to kind of say it i was
like i feel like a dick saying this but
i
honestly like it's this is again this is
the situation
dan are you paying me to record this or
am i paying you to edit this thing right
like
which way does it go because right now
you're telling me how i need to do it
but i pay you
to put this podcast out right so like
again it feels like a total [__]
thing to say
in a mentality but man it's like been
very effective i've used this like 10 or
15 times
the last two months of just reminding
myself what is the arrangement here oh
person from the bank is calling me hold
on
wait a minute do you do you do i work
for you or you work for me hold on which
way does this go
okay yeah yeah all right now i remember
let's do it this way instead
uh and like fights my kind of like just
nice guy get pushed over instincts
all right anyways back to this uh app
real quick
so they have uh the main app the one i
think that's blowing up for them
is called blocker x and basically you
just you go on your phone and you
basically set it to
disable your ability to go to adult
sites maybe on some timer or maybe just
like permanently i don't know
what's like a self-blocking thing and
blocking these sites is actually not
that easy
um and so you want to be able to block
this without blocking other sites
accidentally
and without letting you get through and
so you and so they basically have this
combination of things between like a
community of people like peers like
alcoholics anonymous like here's a bunch
of other people also trying to improve
themselves this way
here's a tool a blocker here's like
gamification a streak
or uh like points you're getting for
continuing on
and i just thought this was kind of
interesting like is there a modern day
aaa
like if people are right that social
media
is the new smoking right that um that
that
all this like kind of like overload of
technology overload of digital
news and information and social media is
making us unhappy and lonely
then isn't somebody going to build the
like aaa for that like that kind of
makes sense to me even though on the
surface it sounds like a weird idea what
are you so i'm trying to
yeah i i think this is great but let me
put some stuff in perspective so i
actually use a site like this i don't
use it for porn but i use it for
uh sure facebook and twitter and things
like that and so i wish i could share my
screen right now but if i go to twitter
right now it says
shouldn't you be busy working and i use
this thing called
stay focused stay focused is a google
chrome extension
yeah it's a google chrome extension i
love it and i just sent it to you
according to stay focused
uh the cool thing about doing research
on chrome extensions is they tell you
roughly how many users they have so they
have roughly 600 000 users but the
biggest person in this space who haven't
done a significant amount of research is
uh research for they have uh it's called
um
it's called a block site the thing i
sent you it's read out how many users
that has
block site it says a million plus users
crazy right
right so that's pretty good that shows
there is a lot of demand because chrome
extensions are not like
mainstream or like that easy to like
find
and you know so so if if a chromecast
has a million users
that is a strong validation of demand
it's huge and so when i look at what
these guys are doing it's kind of
interesting so
what's it called again i got to pull it
up uh how do you pronounce it altmana
and mana their name is not the best
admonish
so i'm looking at what they're doing
it's basically
it starts with a a chrome esque
extension business and then offers more
features to get you well
i think theirs is a mobile app i think
that's i think it's the same as what
you're talking about but with the mobile
app as far as like
their go to market and you can and i
think that's actually your android
i actually think that's a brilliant way
to spin a
thing that's already been around yeah
and to spin it a little bit differently
and i'm on board with this i think this
is great so the way the way we were
talking about um chrome extensions if
you go to the chrome
extension store you can see how many
downloads it has so google play does the
same thing so if you click the google
play button
you scroll down to the bottom of any
google any goo any app on android
you'll see installs and this says it'll
say you know either like
less than ten thousand a hundred
thousand if in this case five hundred
thousand and then it'll say
a million this one's at one million plus
so you know it's between
one and i think ten million is the next
cut off so it's somewhere between one
and ten million
installs on android which again that's
no [__] joke i should invest in this
this is a good idea and i actually just
researched them so they used to be
called this thing called fun switch
technologies
when i heard that name fun switch i was
like i have a feeling that they started
exactly how i thought
and i went to the fun switches uh fun
switches uh
linkedin and it said uh mobile first
solution aimed at the uh
uh uh getting people sorry helping
millennials overcome digital addictions
and helping mental health uh sorry i'm
just reading this as a go are aimed at
using the latest techniques and mental
help to assist people suffering from
those
digital addictions basically it was a
chrome-esque
plug-in and they just spun it to be this
porn thing because they saw that's the
big market to be in
so i think it's really cool i have a
feeling that's what happened i'm just
doing all this
research like as we're talking but kind
of interesting
okay let's do chrome all right so i had
this idea while i was laying in bed this
morning so my my trainer has me do this
exercise
you go what is it called it goes um
kegel exercise
it's a kegel for my brain uh basically
it's a quick
like two minute thing you do you do in
the morning which is called
the events of the day go my way you just
sort of imagine
your day going the way you want and um
and
and it's very simple and and and we do
the same thing at night as a revision
which is
you reimagine something some part of
your day that didn't go the way you want
and you just re
you don't even try to correct it and
self-help and ask why
what's wrong with you why am i such an
idiot you just reimagine it going good
and then you go to sleep
um and this is like such a lightweight
mental hack
but anyways the um i was doing it this
morning and i was imagining this podcast
going great i'm imagining you saying
that is a great idea uh and this is what
came to my mind so then the idea came
which is how crazy is that i imagine you
saying this is a great idea
i had a great idea came to my brain
within like 20 seconds so here's the
idea
a chrome extension that pays you for the
sites you go to
okay let's start there why would a
chrome extension pay you to go to a
website
well websites want traffic right that's
what most ads are
so a website i say i have an ecommerce
store
i know that a visitor on average the
right visitor is worth you know
somewhere between three and five dollars
let's say
um just based on the conversion rate and
the average order value
and so i would be willing to pay a
dollar
for you to come visit my site so here's
what i'm imagining you install the
chrome extension
the chrome extension tells you hey sean
um espn will pay you 30 cents right now
to go to their website
um you know reddit will pay you 20 cents
uh
that you know that pet store that you
buy from they'll pay you a dollar to
come to the site
um just click the button go there and
you just have to be there for for 30 60
seconds or whatever and then you'll
unlock the bounty
and it'll just go into your little piggy
bank right here in the browser it's a
little piggy bank icon
oh okay so so i believe that on one side
you could get brands to basically buy
traffic through a chrome extension
and the money goes to the user um
either split with the with the chrome
extension or just all to the user in
this case
and the user goes there and the user
says ah easy i just have to go to the
site i don't have to buy anything no
problem
but you go to the site you basically
have bought their attention you bought
their impression it
you know they may see something new they
may convert they may check out some new
product that you have because that's
what you drove them to
now how does this uh how does this end
up paying off well
two two things two interesting things
happen here the first
let's say my wife is a big shopper okay
traffic
is going to be worth a lot more than my
traffic because i'm a shitty i barely
shop i just go look at information i
steal and i run away
so i might get low low bids she might
get high bids how does it know how what
to bid well it's a chrome extension it
sits in my browser it sees how much i
spend
it sees what sites i go to it creates a
value score for me and so it knows what
i'm worth
the second thing is when i go to let's
say now
let's so let's so so that's the first
part uh it's like page rank but for
users users are worth
some different amount based on the sites
they go to how much they spend um
it's like unbundling the facebook ad
system so now the second thing
is let's say now i'm a news website and
news websites always wanted this like
micro payment thing like
they want me to subscribe 10.99 a month
or whatever but i don't want to do that
but i would pay like four cents for an
article right i would pay two cents and
this idea of like
ultra micro payments has been around for
a while people want to do this with
crypto people want to do this with
different things
but if you first did the piggy bank
thing by letting users get paid
then you could go to publishers and say
hey pay wall this for like two cents
using that same plugin we have
six million members who um who get paid
daily
using our thing their piggy bank has
money in it all they don't have to put
in a credit card ever
they can just do like tiny micro
payments on their favorite sites when
they go there so i think you could build
a pretty
i think you would change the way the
internet works if you if you did this
all right
tell me about my idea okay so this is
not i don't think new right like the
idea of like
making a little bit of income from the
ad arbitrage and
and incentivizing you to go to a uh i
mean
this is maybe what would i use today if
i wanted to get
paid if i wanted to open up my browser
and see some offers to make money to go
to some of some websites that want me to
go there
um you know the penny holder the
the kind of blog website yeah they made
80 million a year doing something like
that and so
uh kind of like that so they would
they would show all the latest deals and
all the latest like free stuff that you
can get
and they would make a little bit of
money by sending people there and making
that affiliate
but you have to go to the penny order
right yeah so
different but same um similar but
different
correct um so there's this guy named dan
that one of our friends
invested in and told me all about it and
he he's like ugh
this is this is a scam now that's my
friend's words
sorry dad don't hold me to this but i
sent you a link to it it's called
current mobile.us and
that's a similar promise to what this
guy made was basically
you're going to get paid for browsing
the internet passively and i can i
imagine that
it was something like we will pay you
that that
ad arbitrage and i'm almost positive
that it was like the number one app
in the uh itunes store for like a very
short amount of time but number one
nonetheless um and i don't know what
happened to this but i remember he
laughed raised 40 million dollars but
looks like
you're thinking that this isn't doing
gangbusters anymore he
raised i think he raised 40 million
dollars through uh
uh what's it called an ico uh okay
yeah so he's got current token yeah so
there's like a bunch of like
right stuff around here that it doesn't
make sense to me so brave
brave browser also has like a similar
idea the brave browser has bat which is
the basic attention token
so you earn it by going to sites or
whatever and then you
pay you know you're basically like
advertisers can buy the token
to get your attention uh you can you can
basically
like pay the token to like see websites
or whatever but yeah you'll be using a
great browser which is a great browser
if you're doing well
yeah break browser has like 10 million
users or something like that so then
yeah this is a great idea you're just
suggesting it on chrome yeah i think
that's a wonderful idea
yes right all right
my my imagination has my imaginal act
has turned into fact as they say
i think that's a great idea right i
think it's a great idea that's why i
said it i thought i was excited about it
i think
i think that somebody could do this it's
like honey right like honey is the
chrome extension that basically
says cool you just go around shopping on
the internet we'll tell you when we
could save you money because there's
like a discount or a coupon
and then they started shoving in like
kind of some ad slots i was like hey
this person's not even necessarily
looking at this product but you could
make them an offer here
um and so i think that's i think that
it's honey but it's for your foot
traffic basically what is your foot
traffic worth
it's worth something that's a great way
to and that's a great way to phrase it
facebook catches all the value google
catches all the value of your foot
traffic
you get none of that value and so what i
think is that if you could opt in and
say
i'll get paid for my foot traffic i'd
like to see what my foot traffic is
worth
you put the chrome extension in you
start getting offers you start earning a
piggy bank
and then that can be used to just either
you take the money out or you can pay
for things on the websites you go to
and i know that websites will pay for
the right foot traffic if it performs
and i see no reason why this wouldn't
perform
all right let's wrap dan tell us how we
did how was this episode
episode was good i liked all the ideas
give you a 9 out of 10.
all right solid
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back